[Music]
I think the first thing to say about the
story of Adam and Eve is it's one of
innumerable origin stories it happens to
be the most celebrated the most famous
and powerful origin story in our culture
central to Judaism Islam and
Christianity but it's only one of many
many origin stories it seems to be
something that our species does as far
as we know other species don't do it I
don't think that chimpanzees asked
questions about the origin of
chimpanzees or bottlenose dolphins and
sperm whales but we do ask where did we
come from what were the first ones of
our species and this is a it appears to
be a universal phenomenon in culture to
ask about origins and so this is a
crucially significant version of the the
kind of story that is generated and we
might ask why why do we want to know why
don't other creatures want to know well
I think there are a number of different
explanations one is our insatiable
curiosity including something like
scientific curiosity another is our
uneasiness perhaps about ourselves in
the course of our existence why do we
why is it so hard why do we have to
labor why do we draw in the fields when
and we have to have to clear them out in
order to get food from the ground why
can't we just get everything we need
naturally why why do women scream in
pain when they give birth to offspring a
totally natural event that is the part
of the replication of the species I
immense so miserable to women and why do
they put up with it and maybe above all
why do we die so the story addresses in
the incredibly powerful though difficult
way but in very very tight compass it
addresses those questions and more in a
way that human beings appear to want a
need as a way of orienting themselves
the world s way of understanding their
fate the fact that the first humans are
in a garden where they are told that
they can eat of any tree that they want
they're vegetarians they can eat of any
tree in the garden except for one which
they're prohibited from eating and it
happens that the one tree that they're
favorited from eating is the tree of the
knowledge of good and evil and it was
noticed a very long time ago that is to
say several thousand years ago that it's
a problem to be prohibited from eating
of the tree that will enable you to
distinguish between good and evil since
distinguishing good and evil is
presumably what enables you to observe
the prohibition in the first place so
that problem bothered people right away
or at least maybe not right away but at
least 2,000 years ago and then we have
various other problems that they are
warned that they that they will die if
they violate the prohibition he doesn't
explain unfortunately what that means
and since there had been as far as we
know no death in the world up to that
point it must have been rather
perplexing I sometimes think of Adam
hearing this for the first time and
thinking I don't really know what he
means but next time I talk to him I'll
ask him what what do you mean by die in
any case we don't get any explanation
given to the first humans as to what it
is they're being told to beware and in
fact when they encounter the talking
snake when the woman encounters the
talking snake the talking snake says no
you're not going to die you'll become
like a god there there he denies that
that the punishment will be death and
you could say that immediately after the
man and woman eat they don't die so they
keep going on this is a problem that
actually puzzled or many early
commentators why don't they die
immediately since they were warned
that they would die it's a perfect
instance of something that I think
should puzzle us and interest us why is
it that when we look around or when we
look at the polls that are conducted of
our own fellow citizens men and women in
the United States but brought more
broadly in the world so many people
profess to believe in the literal truth
of this literally unbelievable story and
we could say shrug and say it's dog
religious dogma we could say it's the
stupidity or gullibility but I'm not
inclined to say any of those things I
think that this is an incredibly
powerful story it's very good to think
with I think it's extremely naive to
believe that any of us can live without
narrative without stories without myths
we don't even those people who think
that they're not living with myths may
be Spock on Star Trek but but people
don't live lives like that we need ways
of orienting ourselves in the world and
this is one of the great instances in
the history of our civilization an
instance of very complex kind with good
sides and bad sides of people orienting
themselves in the world I'm not the
least bit surprised that millions of
people in our world despite the evidence
of genetics despite the evidence of
geology nonetheless clinging to a belief
in this story when I am reading or
looking at an image or a painting or
listening in music I try to make myself
as alert as possible to what I don't get
what seems to me not to be working or to
puzzle me or not to make sense and
sometimes it actually just doesn't make
sense all right we leave it at that
but actually I think often the thing
that seems incomprehensible is the place
you want to start digging not the thing
you want to let your eyes slide over and
go on to the
part that looks super familiar and easy
so I for myself and I encouraged since
I'm a teacher I encourage my students to
be alert to the stuff that doesn't fit
that looks weird and to think about why
it looks weird and to pay some attention
to that because our temptation as
readers and as lookers listeners our
temptation is just to seize like a
flailing in the ocean the Seas on what
we are familiar with already
but then that gives you tends to give
you what you already know I'm interested
in what we don't know
[Music]